it's lonely today at tom vasilowski's
bar there's no raising a pint here or
anywhere for that matter indeed the only
thing he's raising are the chairs as
government restrictions mandating the
closure of indoor dining come into
effect i don't know how many more times
we can do this i mean
we might have to eventually close down
for a while and hopefully not lose our
staff and that's my biggest worry these
guys have been with me for 25 to 30
years
so they rely on me and i rely on them
tom like so many other small business
owners had hoped they were in the clear
the vaccine passport system was supposed
to allow them to keep the doors open
instead they're stuck in a financial
groundhog day for the fourth time we've
had to lay off staff
you know
people are losing their jobs once again
the canadian federation of independent
business predicted at the beginning of
september that one in six owners
wouldn't make it through the pandemic a
figure that will certainly worsen now
with another round of lockdowns though i
i suspect many will be making the
decision to throw in the towel they just
don't see a pathway back to
profitability
and they're they're struggling they're
drowning with the debt that they've
taken on the latest public health
measures which also includes capacity
limits for retail and closures for
concert venues and cinemas will last
through january 26th an expanded rebate
system announced by the ontario
government was widely panned by business
owners leading to a second announcement
that a grant program is in the works i'm
in a situation where i can somewhat
sustain but it is getting to a point
where it's like
enough is enough i i i'm frustrated i'm
angry and i'm disappointed i'm concerned
i don't usually lose sleep but i'm
wondering how i'm going to pay my staff
business owners say they'd like to
believe the government that this
lockdown will be short but they've heard
that before
mike realight global news toronto